♪ ♪
TO BE TOO ALL RIGHT, AMID A
ROARING ECONOMY, THE TOTAL
COLLAPSE OF THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
CONSPIRACY THEORY, DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE NOW RENEWING CALLS
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
WHY?
IT IS ALL DESPERATE ATTEMPTS TO
DERAIL AND DESTROY TRUMP'S
PRESIDENCY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT MAY WELL BE A TIME FOR AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY TO BEGIN.
SPEAK OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SPEAK OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEA
SPEAK OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTES
WHOLE IS FOR AT LEAST AN
INQUIRY OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> IT HAS REACHED A POINT WHERE
WE HAVE TO OPEN AN IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA NEEDS
TO BE IMPEACHED.
>> WE SHOULD BEGIN IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: HERE AND WITH THE
REACTION IS THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM OF THE
GREAT STATE OF SOUTH CAROLINA.
SARAH, HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD, THANK YOU.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, IT IS
CLEAR NANCY PELOSI IS SPEAKER IN
NAME ONLY.
IT IS CLEAR THIS IS WHAT THE
MEDIA MOB AND THE RADICAL
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING.
NO SOLUTIONS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
A GREAT POLLSTER SAID TO ME
TODAY, THAT COMBINATION OF THE
GREEN NEW DEAL AND IMPEACHMENT
AFTER FOUR SEPARATE
EXONERATIONS, THAT IS NOT GOING
TO WORK OUT WELL, POLITICALLY.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK MEDICARE FOR ALL MEANS
MEDICARE FOR NOBODY.
THEIR RADICAL AGENDA AND DESIRE
TO DESTROY TRUMP CAMPAIGN GOT TO
REMEMBER THIS.
TWO YEARS, MUELLER LOOKED AT
TRUMP.
$25 MILLION, 40 FBI AGENTS, 19
LAWYERS, 2800 SUBPOENAS, AND
THEY FIND NO COLLUSION WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL NOT TAKE
MUELLER AS THE FINAL WORD PAIRED
HERE IS WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN GET THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION FOR
PRESIDENT WITHOUT ADVOCATING FOR
THE IMPEACHMENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WITHOUT A
PRIMARY IF YOU DON'T CALL FOR
TRUMP'S IMPEACHMENT.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THE PUBLIC IS GOING TO KICK THE
DEMOCRATS OUT OF POWER AND
REELECT THE PRESIDENT, IF HE
STAYS FOCUSED ON DOING THE JOB
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: THERE'S A LOT OF
TALK, MUELLER DOESN'T WANT TO
COME IN.
YOU COMMENTED ON PURITY I KNOW
DEMOCRATS, THAT IS STILL
THEIR DREAM, BUT THEIR
QUESTIONS, I THINK YOU AND JIM
JORDAN AND MARK MEADOWS MIGHT
HAVE, THAT ARE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
WHY DID HE KNOW THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA?
IMPORTANT QUESTION.
HE HAD TIME FOR TAXI MEDALLIONS
AND LONE APPLICATIONS,
EVERYTHING ELSE, WHY DIDN'T HE
INVESTIGATE THE DOSSIER?
WHY DID HE ONLY HIRE DEMOCRATIC
DONORS.
WHY DID HE HIRE ONE OF HIS
PEOPLE WHO HAPPEN TO BE A LAWYER
FOR HILLARY CLINTON'S
FOUNDATION?
WHY DID HE HIRE ANDREW
WEISSMANN, LICENSED TO LIE, IN
SIDNEY POWELL'S BOOK, HE WANTS
WITHHELD EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE,
MOST ATROCIOUS RECORD, NONZERO
HE LOST IN THE SUPREME COURT?
WOULD YOU LIKE THE ANSWER TO
THOSE QUESTIONS?
BECAUSE I WOULD PEER AT >> IF
YOU FIND COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA, DID
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO S
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO O
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO P
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO Y
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO U
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO F
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO O
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO M
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO D
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO I
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO G
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO Y
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO O
PRESIDENT TRUMP DO ANYTHING TO B
IS WHAT I WOULD ASK HIM.
THE ANSWER IS NO, TRUMP DID NOT
COLLUDE WITH RUSSIA.
WE KNOW FOR SURE HE DIDN'T.
WE NOW KNOW THAT TRUMP GAVE
1.4 MILLION DOCUMENTS TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
EVERYBODY AROUND THE PRESIDENT
TESTIFIED FOUR HOURS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE DEMOCRATS
WANT AN OUTCOME, THE MUELLER
REPORT DID NOT GIVE THEM THE
OUTCOME THEY WANTED.
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP GOING
UNTIL THEY GET THE OUTCOME THEY
WANT.
AND HERE'S WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IF THE PRESIDENT FOCUSES ON
INFRASTRUCTURE, KEEPING THE
COUNTRY SAFE, HE IS GOING TO
WIN.
NANCY PELOSI IN THAT CROWD IS
GOING TO GET KICKED OUT OF
OFFICE.
>> Sean: IS THERE A
JUSTIFIABLE REASON WITHOUT BROAD
MANDATE THAT MUELLER HAD?
IT WASN'T BROAD, TOOK HIM WAY
OFF COURSE.
HOW DOES HE THEN JUSTIFY THE
MAIN PART OF THE MANDATE, WHICH
IS RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE, AND
IGNORE THE HILLARY DIRTY DOSSIER
FOR RUSSIA?
>> TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, SEAN,
THAT WASN'T HIS JOB.
HIS JOB WAS TO FIND OUT IF
CANDIDATE TRUMP COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIA.
DID OUR PRESIDENT, WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR OFFICE, WIN THE
ELECTION BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS
HELPED HIM?
>> ON WAIT A MINUTE, THOUGH.
HE HAS THE AUTHORITY TO EXPAND
OUT, SENATOR.
>> BUT HE DIDN'T.
THAT IS WHAT BARR IS GOING TO
DO, THAT IS WHAT HOROWITZ IS
GOING TO DO.
YOU CAN SAY IT ANYWAY YOU LIKE,
BUT HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE:
AFTER TWO YEARS OF A POLITICAL
RECTAL EXAM, NOBODY HAS BEEN
LOOKED AT MORE THAN TRUMP.
THEY FOUND NOTHING, BUT THE
ANSWER FOR THE DEMOCRATS IS
TRUMP HAS GOT TO GO.
THEY WILL NOT BEAT HIM AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
IF THEY TRY TO IMPEACH HIM, THEY
ARE GOING TO ENSURE HIS
REELECTION.
I WANT THE     THE AMERICAN PEOL
I WANT THE     THE AMERICAN PEOE
I WANT THE     THE AMERICAN PEOT
I WANT THE     THE AMERICAN PEOO
KNOW THAT BOB MUELLER DID HIS
JOB, LOOKED AT TRUMP EVERY WAY
YOU CAN LOOK AT TRUMP, AND HE
FOUND NOTHING.
THIS IS JUST POLITICAL REVENGE.
IT IS GOING TO BLOW UP IN THEIR